so this presentation on improving
conversion rates it's designed to mostly
focus on like landing pages but all of
the principles and ideas that I'll talk
about in this talk actually can help you
improve the conversion rates of almost
anything any user interface so keep that
in mind
this is a typical example conversion
rate funnel and when you're trying to
improve one conversion rate you're
basically trying to improve the
efficiency of going from one step to the
next and the thing is why we care about
conversion rate is because it's part of
two different aspects of growth the two
main sort of drivers and so growth is
kind of like the balance between
conversion and churn and basically
growth happens as a gap between the two
something to keep in mind is that
working on churn is actually much easier
than working on conversion so in this
talk we're working on the harder thing
it's the thing that usually are going to
get started when I talk to a company and
I'm trying to help them with their
conversion rates the first thing I
usually try to figure out is do we even
need to be working on this at all so the
only time you should be working on and
improving your conversion rate is
because you have a leaky bucket so I'd
like to just talk about a couple of
benchmarks into industry so that we've
all kind of sit on the same page and
understand whether like we should be
working on this or working on something
else like putting more things into the
top of the funnel share where conversion
rates here is about 0.5% so basically
this is old-school like before the
internet if people just released
software out for free and they just hope
that somebody will pay for it or have
their own goodwill this is the
conversion rate you can expect casual
download games it's about 2% so stuff
that you sort of play on and off while
waiting in line
most companies kind of care about this
one freemium software as a service
companies they range between 1.5 and 5%
on average it's about 3%
so once I talked to a company and they
have pages that are converting at about
three percent and that is from like out
of a hundred visitors that visit your
page two to three percent sign up I used
to say you probably don't need to spend
that much more time on this probably
other things you should work on instead
that being said you can do much better
than that flicker it back in the heyday
I had a conversion rate between five and
ten percent
Adult Friend Finder so depending on what
you're selling people wanted a whole lot
more so ten the twenty two percent for
sex and end of loneliness even better so
these are if you don't recognize them
children's social networks and so
basically this is the conversion rate to
get your kid to shut the [ __ ] up right
to leave you alone TurboTax Online the
monster seventy percent conversion rate
basically you're going to TurboTax
you're downloading that software you are
paying for it it is very very high
intent every conversion rate problem
looks like every other user interface
problem and the concept or framework
that I'd like to use to explain how to
solve any user interface problem is
using something called the knowledge
spectrum this was created by a amazing
interface designer named uh Jared spool
and basically the knowledge spectrum
says that this represents all knowledge
on a spectrum and on this side
represents zero knowledge no knowledge
you don't know anything and another side
is God like all knowledge your product
and your user sits on two points on that
line just two dimensions your user sits
here at what we call the current
knowledge point
and your interface your landing page the
thing you want them to do is it's here
at the target knowledge point and every
interface problem that's trying to be
solved is trying to close what we call
the knowledge gap that's it
you don't need to go to a complicated
design school to know how to solve these
problems you either going to increase
the amount of knowledge that is needed
by your user or you need to decrease the
amount of knowledge needed to use your
product or interface that's it
and I whenever I'm looking at anyone's a
design problem I'm trying to figure out
do I need to increase knowledge or do I
need to decrease it so the most helpful
exercise that I will use from this once
I understand this concept when I'm
trying to design a landing page or to
improve it is to simplify things very
very simply and what I imagine is
something called the one-button
interface so let's imagine that we
reduced our landing page our product to
just one button on a page the question
becomes what do I have to put on this
page to get someone to push the button
what's the minimum amount and that's
what you want do you want to have on
there and now is there any information
that I put on this page that keeps me
from pushing the button or is there any
lack of information that keeps me from
pushing the button now for every time
that I deal with any page that I'm
looking at that I'm trying to help
improve I basically go through a series
of seven questions for every single one
and then through the series of seven
questions I look very smart you now can
be smart on your own the first question
I ask is what's the call to action is
the button is the thing I most want my
user to do is it super obvious where do
I find it and the thing to keep in mind
about the call to action is it should be
really really close to a concept I like
to call the magic moment
the magic moment is basically the
experience the knowledge the information
the interaction that someone has with
your startup and all of a sudden they
get tingly inside the light bulb goes
off they go holy [ __ ] I've been waiting
for this my whole life
I now get it this is super exciting I
can't wait to use this and your call to
action should be as close to that magic
moment as possible that when I click
that button I'm gonna be taken to that
point so often I go through a design
critique with someone I'm like what's
your magic moment and then somehow the
call to action is like 27 steps away
from whatever it is that makes someone
feel special or gets really excited
about your product or app so do you
should be as close to zero as possible
from your call to action the six other
questions we're gonna go through
relatively quickly and then we're gonna
go through two examples from people
participating in start-up school just
watch them in action the next question
is what is this what is this magic
moment right and my test for this my
lips the MS test is like can I just copy
paste a sentence on this page the
sanding page that I can put into an
email and send it to my mom
and my mom goes I understand what this
is 99% of time I look at people's
websites and they're so filled with MBA
marketing jargon and talk that there's
no sentence that exists on that page
that'll lets me to very clearly
understand what it is that this company
does is it right for me so people who
are super in a rush
impatient trying to solve their problems
they're quickly trying to identify
themselves there's like am I in the
wrong place is this the right product
and the way they're trying to determine
that is to see like is there any
reflection of themselves in this or any
reflection of their problems look at it
anywhere on the page is it legit so the
threshold is very low here just can't
look like a Russian spamming website
right outside of that
you don't need to overthink this thanks
to tons of templates and themes out
there you should be able to get over
this bar very very quickly who else is
using it so a lot of people are
uncomfortable using a product unless
they know that there's something else
out there and you might think it's a
variation of legette but again this bar
is completely different it's letting me
kind of know Oh a shortcut for is it
right for me and is it legit and
basically a shortcut for trust and
people often are trying to say like oh
if so-and-so is already using this then
I should actually give this a chance how
much is it what's the catch this is the
one that so many b2b enterprise
companies are afraid to put on their
website and which is why we've paired
this talk up with pricing and basically
you should have some empathy how many
times do you go to a website and go like
well I'll use this without knowing how
much it costs sounds good to me
let's just do it no one does that and so
you shouldn't be surprised that your
conversion rates are affected because
you don't tell people how much it costs
or what's the catch so let's say you're
giving away something for free and
really your business models you make
money some other way you should explain
that to people because otherwise people
feel paranoid or worried or feels kind
of weird and then lastly is where can I
get help there's always a percentage of
users who will go to your website no
Matt no it doesn't matter that you have
all the fa Q's you've written everything
down you've created these beautiful
video documentation they will just go
like I just want to ask someone I just
need to talk to somebody I need someone
to tell me directly and part of it is
some people are just like I just want to
see if there's a real person behind this
that's number one or some people or just
can't be bothered and sometimes it's
easier for them to just directly ask
then navigate through the website and if
you don't make it really easy to find
and contact you or make it look like
that you were going to help them if they
start using the product they probably
won't use it
this talk is so short so that's
basically yeah those are the seven
questions we are now going to go through
two examples start school companies that
um sent their stuff to me and I don't
really have their permission but they
did submit it when they asked to have a
design creat critique done in the serb
school forums so I feel like we're gonna
be okay okay so the first one we're
gonna do is meeting room dot IO all
right first question what is the call to
action what is it that this company most
wants me to do and then what I do is I
basically then try to do that thing and
just follow it all the way through and
just see how far away am i but in the
magic moment so these guys create
virtual meeting room platforms so
basically um we don't have a copy-paste
sentence but basically it's like you
want to meet in VR space with someone
you can use this to help create that
space and create that sort of meeting I
imagine it is get a virtual room right
now there's a lot of things that are
sort of competing with it
for all the call to actions on this page
and then we kind of don't repeat it down
here that reminds me where to go so
let's go to the most efficient get a
virtual meeting room right now and then
on here we have competing calls actions
to download and then we have manage
rooms and then there's a start here to
get to your virtual room which is a
carousel that walks you through seven
steps to finally get to making a room
but none of these are the actual forms
to do it so you have to then go here and
then hopefully you will remember all of
those seven steps in the carousel and
he'll walk all the way through it so
things that I would recommend would be
like I want to
I've always one button that's very very
clear that's what I want you to do on
any given page number two I don't think
this makes it easy to understand and I
can't keep it in my head the follow it's
good that they know all this steps but I
would probably imagine that there's
something that's going to help me
experience that magic moment much sooner
and what I imagine is that magic moment
happens when I finally like make a
booking and I meet with someone in a
room together and we start interacting
and we're solving something and I feel
like if I can't do that right away then
I want to have them be able to
experience it somewhat so I would
totally add some kind of video I think
they have that kind of here that will
kind of show it off this is this video
is kind of long and it doesn't get it to
that sort of magical place so that's
number one second what is this so
virtual meeting room platform but if I
copy and paste it then I wouldn't quite
know also you see this carousels kind of
moving around
carousels don't work very well because
you're hiding information that I might
want to have to answer any one of my
seven questions and secondly oh god I
can't figure out we do this thing where
he calls in an open beta and so the
legit part here starts getting it
affected it's like oh I can't rely on
this and then later on the signup page
it talks about entering into the closed
beta and so these are all things that
indicate is like I'm not ready for you
to experience this don't use me for any
real meetings so what this sort of
Telegraph's and so if this basically
works I would try to move that straight
forward to there down here we're trying
to look for like who else is also using
that so we don't have a list of
customers instead we have a bunch of
other logos here in terms of featured in
a bunch of press that we have partners
glad you don't know what that means and
then we have a bunch of awards but none
of them are actual people using it and
so it's so many logos of other things
that it would make me nervous that no
one's really using this as a result and
then
lastly what do I get out we've got an
intercom in the lower right and then we
also have no help page no documentation
to quickly sort of look at the see how
this works and then the last one is good
into pricing so here we get to this
point and I realize okay I see this
pricing if I need twelve people in a
room it's going to be $99 a month and
then I can start sort of working on it
and it's one page over and if I go for
the free again we'll go through all this
whole process so a bunch of little
things we just go through all the
questions we can see a bunch of
non-optimal stuff on this page let's go
to our second example feel a little bit
different so this is a company called
div joy and so they described themselves
as a react code base generator and then
he has this one describe just use our
free web-based tool to create the
perfect code base for your next project
so my first question I'm trying to
figure out is like what's the
call-to-action he most wants me to do
and so as I scroll down this page
there's actually nothing that looks like
a giant button and actually the big
thing he wants me to do is click on one
of these templates these screenshots
that are supposed to be the button so we
have sort of an affordance problem and
then we go into here and my magic moment
is when I get over and realize it's like
oh it's not just like landing page
templates but it's like a dashboard it's
like a sign-in page a pricing but it's
like the entire project for building a
SAS app this is all located here which i
think is really amazing and nothing just
tells me that that's what's all here and
I might not find out until I export code
and then I hit download and then I'll
get the code oh yeah so where so many
steps away from sort of experiencing
that and also I feel it's so not
explicit that I might miss how amazing
what he's built here is in terms of what
he's offering
one thing he does kind of well is like
he doesn't have like logos of customers
but he has shown how many people have
created or downloaded the templates so
this number kind of sets that I oh
there's people actually using this and
finding it useful down here he tries to
get at this everything you need is
included and then he adds all this other
text but all that text is there and that
odds are your users aren't going to read
them so because it's located into that
copy
it gets kind of lost and then again we
have an intercom but there's just not
enough information in terms of like
essay cues right an about page that just
makes me go like oh that this is more
than a side project and so in terms of
like how much I can sort of invest in
this and how much I can rely on this
down the road in the future is going to
be minimal as a result great
you